[Music]
we're still cool
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and if there is symptomatic no
absolutely not you start housing
patients who look healthy at the Civic
Center
you're gonna break quarantine
wait oh my god no don't touch him the
National Guard's holding a position
until the army gets here no worse
thought that doesn't come close six
can't even say it's a terrorism work
something else
I've got no operational jurisdiction
get them to let go a little we're not
the enemy here
this isn't terrorism they still need us
send thermite doc and I need one of the
Russians I'll explain later
and six send them fast before disolved
winds down
[Music]
the parasite is building a nursery it's
a big one infection comes son of a [ __ ]
Jordan we're good seriously briefing is
in a minute you're pulling apart the
explosives look at horses Liza I'm just
making sure they got it right
nurseries are the heart of the parasites
ability to adapt to our containment axis
that up there is a nasty piece of work
your turn right the ongoing operations
in the area we can't launch any fire
missions or predator strikes so we're
gonna barbecue the nursery with these
prototype nano-thermite charges before
it goes online can I say barbecue six
won't care no no she
the target is a hot springs resort maybe
she has a vaccine hmm
maybe she has a cure maybe I can stop
working in a quarantine tent that's
lined with claymores and c4 you're a
humanitarian and I'm not sure you can
afford to be you have a direction on the
table because we're barely containing
this and I hope you have a solution that
doesn't involve a nuclear response
I heard the talk
[Music]
okay let's try it your way let's extract
dr. Macintosh and free - god she's got
answers we can use you see three days
before the outbreak NASA tracked a
meteorite that fell into this area we
got confirmation that a local named Boyd
Brooks hauled the object back to his
salvage yard coincidence no he was
trying to sell it online this is why I
called you your highness
so ill very old wait I'm Russian so I
supposed to know something about it I
thought you'd appreciate the heads-up we
can leave the politics to six our job is
to secure it was the plan we move in by
foot and search the area starting with
the house
you